[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka leak skywalker
and that episode was fet for a king in
almost every sense of the word
which i just made up now this is
probably my favorite episode
in the entirety of the mandalorian and
at this point
i think season two is probably the best
star wars that we've had since empire
though it was the shortest one this
season it was actually very sweet
and a may just be in complete fanboy
mode right now
but that's how much i loved it now we're
two episodes away from the finale
and if you've been enjoying the
breakdowns then i'd massively appreciate
it if you hit the thumbs up button
and also subscribe to the channel
because it helps us out in major ways
the force will be with you always if you
do and you know i'd love you
more than mando loves grogu anyway last
week we learned that the child was
actually at the jedi temple on core
ascent
during order 66 but he must have left to
get some snacks because it turns out
that he survived the purge
and was put into hiding the chapter
titled the tragedy follows on from that
with mando on route to tython
in order to place him at the top of the
seeing stone so that he can reach out to
another jedi
grogu has the silver ball that he's been
fascinated over since season one
amando actually gets a response from him
by saying his name
so like it a lump it that's what he's
going to be called from now on
also i don't know if you've noticed but
he actually has a heart shape in the
middle of his forehead
which makes him that much more adorable
and this episode i think they
they really emphasized it quite a lot
amanda gets him to reach out and pull
the ball through the force
which i think hints towards a subtle
little thing
din jaron is of course gutted that he's
gonna have to hand over grogu to one of
the jedi
but i think him going through these
motions shows that he
in the end might actually be the one to
train him i know he doesn't have any
jedi abilities
but he seems to be up for the idea of
putting him through certain processes
and testing his abilities so who knows
down the line the child might stay with
him
i'd much rather have that than have the
pair split up and i actually think this
episode hints towards why they shouldn't
at the end grogu can be seen completely
decimating stormtroopers through the use
of the force
and it seems like he may be turning to
the dark side osaka did warn him that
his attachment and feelings towards
mando
made him too dangerous to train and thus
him acting like this when he separated
does seem to confirm it
who knows we may even end with grogu
being taken to a jedi who thinks the
character is too dangerous to teach
and thus mando must take it upon himself
to do it
he says he can't do it but hey maybe if
he had some guidance himself
from a certain jedi he would be able to
either way there's a lot of things that
could be going down but of course
leave your thoughts below armando also
says dank ferric
which is a curse in the star wars law
actually thought it was the name of
bulk at hands mate at first so thanks
everyone for correcting me
and it turns out this is actually a
curse word that popped up all the way
back in season 1 episode 1
when mithral said it after being
captured i love that they're dropping it
here and it just
adds a lot more to the universe now they
arrive at tython
and this too is steeped in star wars
lore tython is in the system of the deep
core
and it was actually a pivotal location
for the jedi
which is what the order was called
before they shortened it slightly
the group realized that they could split
the force in two and thus the sith and
jedi were formed
and a galactic war broke out on the
planet the settlers of taithon
eventually reached out into the galaxy
and thus the order was formed which
brought peace to it for generations
mano takes grogu to the seeing stone and
we can actually see blue winged
butterflies around the area
these have actually appeared several
times when our characters have been on
endor
and typically they are used as
messengers grogu is of course trying to
send a message here
so i do appreciate their usage things
seem to be going off without a hitch
but if something seems too easy often
times it isn't
this episode is of course titled the
tragedy and a big spanner in the works
comes with the arrival of slave 1
piloted by none other than boba fett if
you remember the bounty hunter game for
the ps2 in which you play jango fett
you'll recall that you stole the ship
and it has remained in the fett family
since then
i absolutely love it and with the
millennium falcon it's probably one of
my favorite vessels in star wars lore
be honest yet who didn't fanboy out when
they saw this flying in
you're lying if you said you didn't now
it turns out that fett just wants his
armor back
and i'm actually still a bit confused
over why he didn't try and take it from
cobb vance
vance refrigeration perhaps he was
waiting until he had an
ally who we learned in this episode is
fenix shant
their partnership was of course teased
all the way back in season one
and it turns out that he fitted her with
cybernetic parts after she was left for
dead by toro
though it was never confirmed we do know
that shand was an imperial sharpshooter
and personally i believe that she was
part of gideon's unit
and may be aware of his headquarters
which we'll talk about later in the
video
now seeing fair is awesome and
throughout the saga
though i loved him i never really had a
response when people used to say he
pretty much
missed a magooed his way through
everything however here he
writes all those wrongs and shows just
how much of a badass he is
fett simply wants his father jango's
armor returned to him
and he has shan sitting on top of a rock
with a gun aimed at grogu
should mando not hand it over i love how
mando threatens them with the whistling
birds
which become a formidable item later in
the episode now mando agrees to put down
his jet pack
and we learn more of their story it
turns out that phet found kinship and
shan
because they were both left for dead on
tatooine and the latter
is now in his service because he saved
her life
plus she's not she's not bad to look at
issue now they almost reach a
negotiation
but unfortunately an imperial troop
carrier arrives and stormtroopers swarm
the area
you may remember this vehicle from the
opening of the force awakens
as finn was dropped off in one at the
start of that movie
mando stupidly leaves his jetpack behind
and things
just go to hell we can also see a
stormtrooper wearing an orange pauldron
and though i'm sure you're aware of what
these are just in case you want
they do not rank amongst the galactic
empire the black coloured pauldron is
for an enlisted trooper
y is for a sergeant and orange is for a
unit leader
which is why we see this guy bossing
everyone around
fett completely decimates them using a
tuscan raider spear
and we finally see why most people try
and avoid them on the desert planet
as they're pretty lethal shand also
fights back in
amazing fashion and using her sharp
shooting skills she manages to take down
several troopers
before they set up an e-web heavy
repeating blaster that fires back with
incredible force
using her environment she manages to
kick a boulder that becomes dislodged by
a mortar
and then takes out the placement it's an
incredible action scene
and for someone that was worried about
this potentially being a fella episode
i was so glad to be proven wrong fett
decides that enough is enough and he
goes to the razor to take the armor
himself
and watching him arrive was absolutely
amazing
this is the kind of character moment
that we've wanted to see in live action
since the guy fell into the sarlacc and
it was incredible seeing him
finally getting his hero moment i also
love how
the armor actually fit him and you must
admit it was quite funny seeing it
hanging loose on cobb band
all the way back in episode one now
unfortunately mando isn't able to get
groggy out of the area
because he's reaching out through the
force which has created a protective
barrier around him
though fett takes the troop transports
down with a two-for-one air
gideon decides that enough is enough and
not only destroys the razor crest
but he also sends in dark troopers to
take the child for himself
i was fuming because i just spent 30
quid on a razor crest model
and that order will be getting cancelled
straight away don't you worry about that
disney
now dark troopers are actually a group
of elite stormtroopers that are
considered the best of the best of the
best
so they actually have the dark side
within them and also have some force
training which makes them
infinitely more deadly than your typical
grunt we of course saw moff gideon
preparing them
and they swoop in with ease and take
grogu captive before returning to
gideon's ship to blast off into
hyperspace
this is of course the tragedy that the
title was referring to
but i did hope that we'd hear the
tragedy of darth plagueis the wise witch
don't know if i told you that one before
now fat flies after them and confirms
that the empire are back
which of course worries shand as she
believed them to be long gone
in the ashes of the crest mando finds
that little silver ball
along with the best score spear that he
got from the magistrate last week
this is a weapon that of course works
against lightsabers
and i actually think that mando might
end up fighting against gideon
who we know has the darksaber the pair
definitely need to fight it out
and having these weapons that can
actually combat each other
makes the most sense to me the trio
decide that they will work together in
order to get the child back
and boba brings up how his father too
was a fouling that fought in the
mandalorian civil wars
which of course hints towards the
similarities that he shares with mando
as vet agreed that the child would be
safe in exchange for his armor
they are now in the character's debt and
they journey to navarro where mando
meets with korra
he's actually looking for bill burr and
i think that the next entry will be a
prison escape
in which mando busts him out don't know
how i
came up with that amazing prediction
there but what's interesting is that
nick frost also appears in the lineup
for a split second
so it's likely that he will feature in
the next century too
frost's working partner simon pegg has
of course appeared in several star wars
properties
so it's nice that he's actually going to
be in one too now cara is a martial for
the republic these days
and she doesn't want to hand over the
info initially but upon hearing that
grogu is in danger
she quickly does the episode ends on
moff gideon [ __ ] with him seeing
firsthand that grogu is giving in to the
dark side
and throwing around stormtroopers like
that absolutely nothing
gideon gets out the darksaber likely
highlighting how he has it in order to
juxtapose the staff
that mando is of course in possession of
though he says he's taking him to dr
pershing to harvest him
i actually think that he will want to
keep the child around in order to have
someone under his control
that is powerful in the ways of the
force now as for perishing we know that
he's still alive
but because mando and co blew up the
cloning lab on navarro
he's probably been forced to move
somewhere else as for next time i think
that
amanda will obviously carry out the
prison bust and we will finally get our
big showdown in the finale which airs
the week after that
now there are rumors that jar jar binks
will be popping up in the series
and this comes from daniel rpk who said
the character will be appearing down the
line
i really like daniel and he's got you
know he's got a pretty good track record
when it comes to this stuff
so fingers crossed it's true he actually
hit me up after i posted the plot leaks
and asked if i had any others
so he's he's probably been losing the
force to get rumors out of people
in order to come up with this at the
moment this series actually seems to be
writing a lot of wrongs in the star wars
franchise
so i i would be down if he popped up as
we've just seen how how a bit of
redemption can go a long way
now as for how things are gonna happen
going forward i think that when mando
actually meets back up with grogu
he'll see a completely disheveled
character that has likely been twisted
by not only gideon's experiments
but also the dark side now he's not
going to remain bad forever
and you know that little silver ball he
picked that up for a reason
and i think if he is bad all amanda will
have to do is like
look at look at the ball remember the
good times and things will be back to
normal but
you know they have an opportunity here
to do something really left field
so who knows what's gonna happen anyway
that concludes another excellent episode
of the mandalorian and obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the entry
in the comments section below
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up make sure you check out
our breakdown of who grand admiral
thrawn is if you want to know the ins
and outs of him
or or just after a quick catch up don't
forget we're giving away three copies of
the lord of the rings 4k box set and all
you have to do to begin with the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of december so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see contents early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chapters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you in the best i've been poor
let's see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you